كما هو الحال في كل يوم منذ بدايه حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا تحتدم المعارك بين
الجانبين وتتعرض الاستراتيجيات العسكريه
لكليهما للاختبار في الميدان الملتهب
القوات الروسيه وصلت هجماتها المكثفه على
منطقه كييف بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
وقالت الاداره الاقليميه للمنطقه ان
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت عددا من
المسيرات فوق غابات المقاطعه
ناحيه اخرى تؤكد روسيا استمرار عملياتها
في محاور لمن وباخمت ومارينكا ومحيطها وان
اعنف الاشتباكات جرت في باخمت ومارينكا
وان مدفعيتها الثقيله دمرت مجموعتين من
القوات الاوكرانيه في باخموت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اعترفت بان
القوات الروسيه تحقق تقدما في باخموت
لكنها لم تسيطر عليها وان معارك عنيفه
تدور في ضواحي المدينه الجنوبيه الغربيه
كذلك تحدث مصدر عسكري روسي عن استهداف
نقاط انتشار من سماهم بالمرتزقه والقوات
الخاصه في مناطق بدونيتسك الخاضعه للسيطره
الروسيه وتقول مراسله الجزيره ان القصف
الاوكراني استهدف وسط دونيسك واحياء محيطه
بها في اقليم الدومباس في شرق اوكرانيا
وفي محور شبه جزيره القرم تقول السلطات
الروسيه ان دفاعياتها اسقطت مسيرات في
الشمال وتزامن ذلك مع اتهام مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي للمخابرات الامريكيه
بالتورط في تفجير جسر القرم وخط انابيب
الغاز نورد ستريم وهجمه ارهابيه اخرى جرت
اخيرا
في هذه الاثناء ابلغ الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قاده مجموعه السبع المجتمعين في
هيروشيما دعمه لمبادره مشتركه تهدف الى
تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات مقاتله
من الجيل الرابع بما يشمل مقاتلات 16
ويقول البيت الابيض انه خلال فتره التدريب
تلك سيقرر تحالف الدول المشاركه في هذا
الجهد موعد تقديم الطائرات وعددها ومن
سيقدمها
وتربط اوساط مختلفه نجاح اي هجوم واسع
يمكن ان تنفذه القوات الاوكرانيه ضد مواقع
روسيه متقدمه بالتفاصيل الميدانيه الدقيقه
لتلك المواقع فمثل ذلك الهجوم اذا وقع
سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا لفاعليه المساعدات
العسكريه الكبيره التي قدمتها وتقدمها دول
الناتو لاوكر انيا وهو امر تدرك ابعاده
القيادات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وتتحسب له روسيا
[تصفيق]